I want to jump to this story it's an old
story but last night we were discussing
a video that came out from the Atlanta
airport that showed what appears to be a
drill sergeant guarding a room full of
illegal immigrants while an NGO was
inside that brags boasts they
facilitating these uh uh migrant uh
traveling around the country the
speculation at the end of the show was
someone said this is where uh people go
for basic training and so we do have
some updates nothing I can say
definitively but if you were to lay out
all the pieces in this story it would
look like there are a bunch of criminal
aliens being brought into the airport in
secret under guard of a drill sergeant
potentially to be recruited into the
military I'm not saying that is true it
does also it's it's all it's entirely
possible that guy just happened to have
been sitting there that's right a drill
sergeant in the airport sitting in a
chair in front of this room full of
illegal immigrants just because he was
there and he was waiting for a plane or
something somebody reached out to us and
they said that uh uh they may have
information and they think uh based on
what they know I don't want to get too
much into it for for privacy reasons the
individual may have literally just been
standing there completely unrelated it
may be that the room in question was a
Uso room that was allowing criminal
aliens to use his facilities and either
way this drill sergeant according to the
state senator who had his camera taken
from him was guarding illegal immigrants
it does not mean he was ordered to do so
it could just be he as an individual was
sitting in front of this room preventing
people from interfering in an operation
that was smuggling humans now many
people pointed out to me that in fact
the US has been making attempts to
enlist non-citizens for some time we
have this from Stars and Stripes Senate
Bill renews effort to enlist
non-citizens in the military okay
there's been a lot to talk about World
War II we got this one from uh Newsweek
you love Dan crenchaw I believe it's Dan
kencha who said this talk of World War
III should not deter strikes inside Iran
yikes okay I guess but there absolutely
is a fear that we are inching towards
World War II Germany Sweden the UK
Australia have all started conversations
around reinstating the military draft in
fact Sweden has always had one but
they're telling their citizens to get
prepared for war and now young swedes
are starting to consider whether or not
they will be conscripted in the UK a
high-ranking uh military officer said
it's time to train a citizen Army which
is cons conscription for National Guard
I guess you can call it and in Australia
they were having conversations about a
push to create a civilian Army to defend
the country in in if War were to break
out in the United States of course we
are facing massive shortfalls in
Recruitment and then you get this video
that looks like it may be criminal
aliens going through some kind of
recruitment process I say looks like I'm
not saying it is take a look at this
from The New York Times this is a story
from January 5th 2024 to bolster
Russia's Army Putin eases citizenship
path for foreign Fighters he's seeking
to strengthen his military to fight in
Ukraine while mobilizing potentially
unpopular mobilization of
Russians if Russia is doing it other
countries have used mercenaries
throughout history I believe the
likelihood that the US plans to or is
actually in the process of using this
Mass influx of criminal aliens using
them for war it's extremely likely now a
lot of people said duh we've all said
this yes we've talked about that very
prospect on this show six seven months
ago but now it's starting to seem more
like a reality and I think we need
members of Congress probably not going
to be Democrats have to be some
Republicans demanding answers and
questions as to what we saw in this
video and finding out whether or not
there are plans to use non-citizens
coming through the border illegally
these fighting age males to enlist them
in the military and have them fight in
the event there's a major a major war
I'm going to say this if you were in
charge of a country and you could not
get people to join up and you feared
World War II was coming I think most
people would be like we'll take
mercenaries we'll take anybody we can
and I think this is one way they're
looking to do it it it just seems like
the logical path and I don't think some
people have said Tim that would mean
these people care about the United
States no it doesn't it means they care
about their home in Wilmington Delaware
it means they're like hey I got a
million dollar property in Santa Monica
and the only way that stands is if we
don't lose a war they will do whatever
it takes do you think the US would just
say well we're looking at a prospect of
international conflict we have a
shortfall in our troops let's do nothing
or do you think they're going to say
bring them ball in
baby see you go so you're saying there's
not enough trans people joining the
military that they have to have to do
this because I was diversity was yeah I
I thought we were told that diversity
was the the most important thing in
recruitment right now no I I think to be
serious actually they probably they did
increase the amount of trans people who
did join the military but it wasn't
enough well it's not enough to bolster
their ranks but the truth is when they
offered uh uh the the the surgeries and
things like that there was a big push
from trans people being like like I'll
sign up free free you know gender
affirming care sexation but uh outside
of that yes the wokeness in the military
has utterly destroyed it and so I have
to wonder then is it on purpose right
because I knew I knew I met a guy who
was an officer like an actual
commissioned officer who said I was
going to be in it was it was a career
for me and I'm I'm out I'm resigning my
commission because of all the woke stuff
all the anti-white stuff I can't be here
now what's the what's what's their
alternative either they're the stupidest
people in the world or they're
intentionally purging the ranks and then
oh no we have no choice but to to
replace the the soldiers we lost with
non-citizens and a lot of people think
the purpose of these noncitizens to
bring them in is to dramatically alter
the electorate these things are not
mutually exclusive you can bring in all
these people say you're going to go
fight World War III and when you come
home you'll be a citizen and then you
dramatically alter the voting
body but how do you fight for a
country that you know nothing about and
that you really have no aliance to
whatsoever how did the Hessians how did
any mercenary group how many how many
how many military contractors in the
Middle East the other night surge
brought up I think it was Surge that you
know during the Civil War a lot of Irish
were coming over and right the boat the
musket go to war I think part of the
issue is you know yes they could
literally pick up guns and fight and
maybe like hear commands or whatever
else but what happens afterwards like
theoretically if you're a citizen and
you're a soldier you get access to the
GI bill when you come back to the US
are you coming back with the idea that I
have served my country are you saying
like cool now I get some other benefits
if you never really acclimate to being
someone who feels a p like it's very
different than people who enlisted
thinking this is something I'm doing in
service of our country which I just
don't think our generation has really
had I think it's something that was in
the past and I think saying you know
there might be someone who says oh well
I really feel as though I served the
country and now I'm a citizen and you
know feel that effect but I think for
the most part if it's transactional if
you're saying oh well I'm doing this so
I can get in and actually I'm going to
not really acclimate in any way I'm not
going to take on our a culture because
right now it's very hard to describe if
we have I mean I really don't think that
there is a unifying American culture
that even people who migrate here with
the best of intentions can seriously
click into and that's just very
different than other points in history
including the Civil War when there was
sort of something there that people were
buying into I I got to tell you if
you're a conspiracy theorist who
believes that there's a bunch of global
Elite want to take over the world or
whatever the best thing for them would
be World War II it reduces population
and it creates enough damage and
Devastation that it gives you an
opportunity to en enforce an
international governing body we've seen
this we've seen this every time I mean
if you look at the Civil War Powers went
went from the states instantly to the
Federal Government after the war was
over if you look at World War II you get
the creation of the liberal economic
order if there is a World War III that
causes massive population reduction I
mean a lot of these population the
malthusians are going to be very happy
but then you have cities in disarray you
have uh I mean actually look at this way
the NHS the reason why Europe has
nationalized healthcare for the most
part is because of World War II after
everything was decimated and destroyed
their economies were ruined they had no
choice but to be like all these people
injured and damaged from the war need
treatment and so that's the evolution of
it us doesn't have that imagine what the
world would turn into if there was a ma
Major World War III and then From the
Ashes the powers remain say if this
happens one more time there will be no
Earth so we're creating the global order
structure or whatever you want to call
it and all countries will abide by its
rules it will be based out of they'll
create some kind of military force like
the capital and Hunger Games I'm not
saying literally I'm saying an
opportunity for dramatic change comes
from war the reason the left would be
happy to get a civil war is because the
Constitution is gone the reason why the
world economic Forum Davos Elites would
love World War III is that it allows
them to completely overwrite government
bill like basically get rid of all the
different constitutions and guarantees
of all the different countries but I I
was just to say in my conspiracy brain I
I've been like thinking about what this
a World War III would even look like and
I keep thinking like a World War I is
mostly drones and less people right and
so the conspiracy thing for me kicks in
where I'm like these people should they
become soldiers are going to be used
against our own citizens what would the
drones attack what would the who knows
targets like that have weapons you know
uh missiles ground uh leaders of some
sort but if the weapons are all mostly
drones the drones will be used to take
out infrastructure right but they'll be
like operating from like a a ship out at
Sea you know and then what happens when
you know you're in you're in New York
and all of a sudden way up in the sky
you can barely see at a tiny Speck MH
fires a missile and blows up the
Williamsburg Bridge yeah but I I'm
sitting here thinking to myself if you
wanted to create a military that really
had no particular allegiance to the
American people or its own citizens that
at any point point you could turn on the
American people or weaponize against the
American people wouldn't you do it with
people who came to this country with no
particular allegiance to to the culture
to the country to the people that aren't
to each other and en list them in the
military and you know not just operates
federally it's not even like they have a
home state that they're like I would
like to go back there and be a part of
this community right exactly I I mean
these people would have no reason to say
that no I'm not you know we're talking
about my parents my grandparents my the
country that I care about they're just
like okay big lessons from the Civil War
when the when the generals had to ask
themselves am I going to fight for my
country or my home and many of them said
my home is Virginia or my home is you
know uh uh South Carolina and they and
they left these people come in they
their their home is I don't care I mean
I don't know it's one place right so
imagine what happens if we get a World
War I I guarantee you if the strikes
that they're proposing on Iranian
targets not Iran directly but Dan kcha
certainly wants it but actual Iranian
Assets in the region and this escalates
one step at a time until we are
literally in World War II before there's
not going to be a formal Declaration of
World War II Joe M's not going to go be
like we hereby announce World War II and
let's go baby it's going to be one step
at a time we will find ourselves in it
facing a military shortfall which
everyone already knows about Biden gives
a state of the unit address saying
therefore I signing an executive order
under my powers in the state of
emergency to enlist noncitizens in this
country to bolster our numbers it's
basically Star Wars Clone
Wars you guys have seen that one right
no I haven't yeah you haven't no oh you
know guys don't get you don't know this
oh man well let me tell you basically
the separatists want to leave the
Republic and they they're blockading a
planet the Republic does not have a
military force that can stop them
Obi-Wan finds a planet that's
mass-produced clones and they're like
it's your army there's an entire Army of
clones available at your disposal and so
they go back to the planet and they're
like what should we do and they're like
if we use these clones we can actually
repel the separatist so they say yes and
then the emperor says now that I have
all these clones who have no allegiance
to anybody we'll do whatever I say he
says go kill all the Jedi so this is
quite literally like the real life
version the US needing to bolster its
numbers for a potential World War II
says we can use all these non-citizens
when that war is over and these people
come back you will have Stormtroopers
who don't care about you don't care
about your state don't even know the
name of most of the cities in this
country and they will do whatever the
federal government tells them to do and
the federal government's been telling
them that most of the citizens here are
evil extremists who vote for the allong
and they actually hate yeah they hate
you they don't even want you here so if
you were you know to turn against them
it wouldn't matter that's why we held
the curtain open for you to sneak in and
here's a gun and come back with crazy
PTSD from whatever War we sent you to
it's not just the United States though
MH if if the US I I mean and and I don't
know the probability of something like
this happening but let's say us bombs
Iran Iran immediately declares fullscale
mobilization US starts talking to its
allies saying guys it's getting hot we
need to make moves and then before you
know it within a couple months no one
declares it but missile strikes Air
Raids troop mobilization in Pakistan
it's heating up World War III Joe
Biden's invoke you know invokes a state
of emergency gives a State of the Union
Address saying we need more troops the
numbers are not enough we will not lose
there are many he's going to say like
migrants he's not going to say illegal
immigrants he say many migrants in this
country love this country and will fight
for it and we are going to offer them
that opportunity he then creates this
massive military force once the
international conflict subsides and
there's mass destruction in death you
now have the opportunity for a global
elitist or whatever to say we can never
allow this to happen again therefore we
will be creating a a global governing
body to adjudicate disputes between
factions with an international military
force called the global task force or
whatever and it will be these people who
come from countries where they don't
quite care enough they leave they will
have no problem going to Europe to
Russia to China and so there will be
non-national military forces that's a
potential I'm not saying it's true I'm
saying the dominoes are lined up as such
it could land that way it's not good I
don't like it no I'm so glad I have
Insurrection on my record so I like I'm
never going to be forced to enlist like
though it can't happen I used to be able
to play the gay card but that's no good
anymore not the Insurrection card but
but how old are you 47 you're too old
come on I I'm too old I I committed
Insurrection and well I'm gay but did
you it would be that Insurrection would
get you out of the army and not the gay
I I never dreamed we did up here but but
it is funny that you used to be too gay
they were like actually we changed our
mind like that's fine Insurrection
you're way low on intersectionality
scale now right right yeah right you're
you're a white male yeah and and uh gay
is still s heteronormative I believe
right oh no is it not it's problematic
it's problematic it
is I don't know man World War II or no
what do you guys think I keep thinking
well I kind of feel like we've been in
it and just not to finding it as such
for a long time but I I was just going
to say I keep way with all International
conflicts yes right thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a member
over at timcast.net